Josh thank you so much for coming actual
show very nice to see you again
absolutely good to be back great to have
you here because you've been writing a
lot about Chris Christie I have and I
will you at all surprised by this sort
of behavior and the governor well I was
surprised by the specifics of the George
Washington Bridge thing like it was a
like an egregious abuse of power I
believe the governor didn't know about
it in advance but the thing is that you
know for four years part of the way he's
governed the state is by this sort of
petty politics of retribution and favors
that you give out to local officials and
members of the legislature but in a lot
of cases it's actually been a good thing
when people thought that was a point of
getting elected right well but also like
when when people talk about why they
like Chris Christie they tend to say
things like well he brings people
together and he gets things done how
exactly do they think he's been doing
that like you know partly it's about who
knows it's well know it's because he's
been a centrist it's and part of that is
about picking issue positions that
people like and listening to people and
he's generally done a pretty good job of
that but it's also you make people feel
like they'll be better off being with
you than being against you and you use
the powers that are available to the
governor's office to bring municipal
officials and members of the legislature
in line and he's got a lot of
substantive achievements with the
Democrats who run the legislature in his
state and if you want to see what a
government looks like when people don't
do that you just need to look to
Washington where the president has very
little power to punish either members of
his own party or the other party who
don't do what he wants in Congress
leadership in Congress because they've
gotten rid of your marks basically have
no way to buy off members of their party
and so when that happens people just get
very ideological they don't make deals
and the governments of the falls apart
so in New Jersey you've gotten four
budgets that have been agreed to by both
parties passed
early you've gotten various major
reforms done and the governorship more
or less his work doesn't mean he should
have shut down the bridge like you no
that was that was an overreach but when
you talk about you know well how much
how much less petty should the
government be there's somewhere and he's
yes like a [ __ ] sometimes he's I
think his administration has crossed it
but you don't you do want some amount of
this stuff where you have the governor
putting pressure on people to get into
line because that's how compromises are
made in politics
I think you know people talked about
earmarks being a big waste but there
were a very small part of the federal
budget they did a lot to grease the
wheels in Congress and to get people not
to do to get people to come to
agreements I had I was talking with a
former official in administration who
was talking about you know why it's so
important to have earmarks he's like
well if you don't have your marks how
are you gonna people get people onto
your side not on the merits they don't
care about the merits and I think that's
basically right I think Christie for the
most part has found a way to make
government work it's just a question of
making sure that people don't go
overboard and I think what it
demonstrated as administration has run
amuck and particularly his his defense
of it was kind of embarrassing where
he's saying well you know I didn't know
what happened I'm so angry at these
people he's saying I have an
administration people who are out of
control and aren't telling me what
they're doing right that was a problem
he needs to rein them in but he only
needs to rein them in so much